[Musique]
nous sommes aujourd'hui au large du grau
d'agde petits ports de la côte
méditerranéenne qui prolonge la ville
d'agde comme chaque matin après avoir
passé la nuit en mer les chalutiers
regagne le port tandis que les pêcheurs
salle harbour s'affairent à trier la
marée du jour sur le quai germaine la
poissonnière mon ami germaine l'un des
personnages les plus hauts en couleurs
du grau d'agde les attend déjà pour
faire sa provision de poisson qu'elle
ira vendre comme chaque jour sur l'un
des marchés de la région
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous suivons aujourd'hui germaine au
marché de mont blanc un de ces petits
marchés de l'arrière pays où elles
aiment retrouver ses clients fidèles
[Musique]
mais germaine ne se contente pas de
vendre ces poissons
elle a la bonne habitude aussi de
conseiller ses clientes sur la façon de
les accommoder et la recette qu'elle va
vous proposer aujourd'hui c'est celle de
la roussette à la tomate ou vers 7h
alors vers mais nous voilà maintenant
dans votre cuisine pour préparer dans la
rue la roussette à la tomate
qu'est ce que vous faites voilà je suis
en train de nettoyer des roussettes
voyait voilà il faut les bleus il faut
les enlever leur oui je te facile à
faire y'a plus difficile que ça y voilà
12 et ménagères saveur c'est à dire que
non moi je le fais parce que je sais mon
métier je suis poissonnière je vend du
poisson je vends des roussettes et toute
la matinée je peine 0,7 à mes clients
parce que j'attends beaucoup de la salle
et c'est tout les poissonniers le font
ça pour l'heure mais oui
je crois bien quand même ce n'est pas
soigné dans le faire pour leurs clients
qu'est ce que c'est comme boisson la
recette là on sait que c'est un poisson
qui vit dans les grands fonds sont
dévoilés très certainement de presse que
des fois la chaîne non non c'est pas
cher mais ça vaut dix francs les sept à
tête pour vous allez vous faire voir
il faut laisser cinq ans mourier alors
on les coupe en trois morceaux
voilà en écopant de trois morceaux
voyait là bon avant d'aller plus loin
germaine
j'aimerais que vous nous disiez ce qu'il
faut exactement pour préparer ce plat
bruce est alors la rousse est d'abord un
kilo de recettes
un kilo de jolis thomas terre avec un
peu de persil voilà puis alors de la
reine ont messi goudal un peu de thé du
long que cognac de connell pourquoi pas
pour faire de la route et de la farine
de l'huile
non ce n'est pas une pourquoi l'huile la
farine pourquoi avoir farine et des
recettes de celle du sel du poivre et
bien là et on va on va préparer la boue
cette voie là parce que ce serait trop
long dans la poêle et voyez c'est plus
présente
voilà alors maintenant je prends un plat
je mets les roussettes dans le plat et
qu'est ce que vous avez fait ces chartes
de les roussettes avec de l'eau
bouillante avec de l'eau bouillante et
voilà je les ai chose pourquoi parce
qu'il faut les aider pour enlever le
sang pour enlever tout ça pour que je
sois plus geste pourquoi les digère
mieux voilà après alors je les méprise
les égoutter dans une passoire dans une
passoire
à l'eau froide pour les raffermir bien
graissée voilà oui mais vous savez qu'à
saint jory voyez elles sont très fermes
vous avez pas dit qui l'est c'est plus
un peu d'eau donc on est chaude et on
refroidit aussi parfois dit de suite
après vous allez voir ce que je vais
faire je vais garder ma place je vais
laisser chez je vais décès chez des
fêtes danses chants de filles
voilà l'un peut accommoder avec ses deux
tours chambre en arrière grand mère est
un pur film tempur fille et dit pierre
pendant que vous me regardez là si vous
voulez peut-être que chez un petit peu
les tomates hors jeu bien si ça peut
voir comment il faut faire
voilà mon cas et c'est la peau à l'eau
avec les boutons carrés c'est la peau
comme ça a bien bien bien oui
m jean poiret été un peu d'huile voilà
j'avais de lui là je vous observe quand
même mairie savez moi je mets de l'huile
la farine les recettes
[Applaudissements]
voilà vous l'avez des prix en juillet je
mets mes recettes à frire
voilà
voilà à poil et plaît bien voyez prb wii
ware
bien très bien de gueule ça va mais le
plat bon président alors après ça qu'est
ce qu'il va se passer
ouais voilà moi pendant ce temps je vais
tourner les roues secteur
alors là vous d'y retourner un voile à
vous et vos tournées maintenant je vais
les verser dans le plat elles sont déjà
cuites la presse que tweets mais pas
complètement presse que plus il faut pas
les faire cuire complètement parce qu'il
faut que ça mais jean tigana tomates
vous comprenez bien parce qu'après en
plaçant sa vie on va faire une bonne
chance maintenant vous allez versailles
oh là là vous allez voir cette source
c'est simplement oui déjà ray commence à
sentir bon ben voilà alors je les arrose
2 cognac ou que c'est dur attendez ça y
est vous servent à quelque chose
voilà les tomates c'était bien on sent
que les câbles est très bien très bien
voilà je les arrose bien de cognin
changement voilà voyons lambert au sec
alors maintenant pendant que ça flambe
ça se fait bon vous avez détail et aux
ratés aussi bien chez d'écouté pierre
puisque vous avez nettoyer tomates que
vous allez toyer et thomas d'accord pour
préparer la sauce pour préparer la sauce
vous nettoyez me gousse d'ail et moi je
vais m'occuper des tomates c'est
d'écouter mes tomates matos pour faire
la sauce n'a jamais pas plus j'avais les
doigts ne pouvait on voir là bas
morceaux voyez jamais le soir on sent le
jus dans les plats comme la tomate ou
cool voilà
voilà je vais attendre un enjeu temps
c'est pas la guerre ici y'a pas de train
qui passe voit la voyez
voyez ça lie avec le persil rossi
doucement à lui relancé
voilà je croisais en fin de compte c'est
un plat qui revient combien 27 femmes à
peu près compter comme ça arrive et puis
c'est un plat comme enjeu six personnes
c'est très bonne recette c'est riche en
phosphates
[Applaudissements]
et voilà sur l'avis ajouté à petit elle
va se cuire
je vais lui mettre du l'envié de teint
dit m je vais écrire les tomates
combien de temps voilà avait à peu près
un petit quart d'heure et voilà alors
quel est ton matin on peut diminuer ce
n'est la bourse est dedans à mijoter
avec des formats
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et bien profitons de ces quelques
minutes de répit que nous laisse la
roussette pour prendre l'air sur le port
du lourd d'agde
[Musique]
et aussi pour demander à germaine de
nous conseiller sur le choix des
poissons puisque c'est son métier en
dehors de la roussette est-ce qu'il ya
d'autres poissons pas trop cher que vous
recommander à voir les sardines ce
moment qu'est ce qui se passe comment
sardines on es bateaux qui arrivent avec
25 points de tous les matins des
voiliers pierre nous sommes sur un
bateau qui a pêché hier 30 tonnes de
sardines
mais vous rendez compte c'est que celle
où il ya des écailles partie et c'est
pas trop cher la sardine à 6 francs le
kilo sur le marché
ouais sur les marchés en gros sa 7ème
prix passées entre les pêcheurs et les
mares hier un peu disposition une wii à
part ça à part la sardine thon c'est pas
cher c'est vrai 10 francs le kilo mais
francky franc de marco rossi après nous
avons des musées de mer qui est très bon
et fait 12 francs le kilo sur le marché
est très bon le musée mer et souvent les
gens négligent ces poissons qui sont
même catégorie les gens se jettent
toujours sur le collège et vous savez
des fois une tranche de collègues ça
vaut une tranche de colas avons aussi
cher qu'un kilo de poisson
oui c'est vrai ça qu est-ce qu on se
connait trés bon marché dont 4 francs le
kilo très bon en gascogne rôti les bords
du citron femmes
l'important c'est de savoir les
accommoder voilà c'est d'avoir une bonne
au service et ça comme celle de la
roussette vraiment que vous nous donnez
aujourd'hui voilà alors ma tomate a bien
diminué tout seul on est parti je vais
prendre mes recettes et je vais les
mettre à me chanter avec les tomates
voilà à faudrait nous abstrait
très doux qu'elle avait minutes tout
petit feu relié à petit petit feu et
pendant ce temps je vous réserve une
petite surprise au mont houy suivez moi
je vous suis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et oui parce que germaine a une autre
passion en dehors de son métier de
poissonnière
c'est la danse espagnole
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ap
car
et voilà je crois que ma recette est
bien mais j'en fais je vais remettre mon
petit tablier
ai je déjà versé d'un mètre
et voilà la recette de jardin
et bien vivre la roussette germaine et
vive les castagnettes
[Musique]